but first more phony science more
damaged kids that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
fear money power those are the three
overriding principles that drove our
governments hideously flawed response to
covid from mandating experimental mRNA
shots to closing schools and playgrounds
to social distancing that was stupid and
masking it was all pandemic Panic an
abuse of powers via emergency orders
big money payouts to the medical
industry
well the brutal truth which we told you
years ago is that they never had any
serious peer-reviewed studies to back up
any of their egregious edicts none
basic principles of Immunology such as
acquired immunity through infection were
ignored
instead the branch covidians relied on
fudge studies with ever-changing
endpoints and sold them relentlessly
with the help of flax masquerading as
journalists
that we're all about the science gang
actually didn't have any science on
their side but they did have Pfizer
Academia and Hollywood with them all the
way
new billionaires were minted in the big
Pharma industrial complex
Tony fauci Deborah Burks they became
media stars and more than anyone our
kids including my own suffered
there was lost learning lost Athletics
missed graduations
while countless others suffered from
vaccine and lockdown-induced harm to
their mental and physical well-being
and now the same forces are at it again
trying to sell us another New Normal
a demonic campaign to destroy the
natural biological order
one where our children are once again
their guinea pigs
and it's all backed by phony science and
big Pharma
it's pushed by radicals in our schools
it's adopted by big business and big
government and of course all the while
it's glamorized by big Tech and the
entertainment industry
Sam graciously wanted me to accept this
award because I'm the first transgender
woman to win this award and I just want
to thank
um all the incredible transgender
Legends before me who kicked these doors
open for me so I could be here tonight
the field of transgender focused Health
Care is also booming
did you know there are now more than 100
pediatric gender clinics in the United
States that's up from zero just 15 years
ago
and let's face a gender transition
surgeries bring cash-strapped hospitals
big money
my friends this is not science
and this explains the Relentless push to
expand gender affirming care even for
young people
as a trans woman I can tell you that
it's not overly dramatic gender
affirming care is life-saving we really
need to be expanding gender affirming
care since starting on my gender
affirming care my confidence and
happiness and overall mental health
well-being has just shot up and I'm
doing so much better so you know we are
living in a time when there's so much
misinformation and disinformation we
have to be very clear that we need to be
listening to trans people
again just like covid you question the
trans Davidians and you're guilty of
misinformation disinformation you're
dangerous
basic principles of science though that
there are two Sexes that DNA is
unchangeable that kids judgment isn't
really developed until their later years
that is all out the window
we know how this story ends
and now the entire sex mutilation
industry is on edge why because a
whistleblower who worked on the inside
is exposing what's really happening to
children in these clinics
a former employee of the Washington
University transgender Center at St
Louis Children's Hospital recounts an
exacting detail how life-altering
treatments are fast-tracked to patients
who are unaware of their long-term and
often life-altering side effects
now first I want you to understand that
this is not some political hit piece
this whistleblower describes herself as
a queer woman politically to the left of
Bernie Sanders
and when she was younger she questioned
her own gender and is currently married
to a trans man
she truly thought that she was saving
these kids and what she was doing but
now she calls it morally and medically
appalling
she explains that more than half of the
new patients were young girls sometimes
there'd be clusters from the same high
school huh
now they often had comorbidities they
suffered from depression anxiety ADHD
Eating Disorders obesity and even autism
to get them ready for the transition
process as it's so benignly referred to
Jamie Reed The Whistleblower writes
about working with therapists to Fast
Track it
to begin transitioning the girls needed
a letter of support from a therapist
usually one we recommended
who they had to see only once or twice
for the green light
to make it more efficient for the
therapist we offered them a template for
how to write a letter in support of
transition
the next stop was a single visit to the
endocrinologist
for testosterone prescriptions
Reed goes on to write that patients were
often poorly informed about drug side
effects citing one case with a 15 year
old male patient who was described who
was prescribed a drug used to treat
prostate cancer one of the side effects
is the feminizing of men's rather or
rather Boys in this case bodies another
side effect is liver toxicity which the
15 year old experienced
he was immediately taken off the drug
his mother then sent an electronic
message to the transgender Center saying
that they were lucky her family was not
the type to sue
and this gets worse Reed says the clinic
operated with a lack of regard for the
rights of the patients themselves in
Missouri
only one parent's consent is required
for treatment of their child
but when there was a dispute between the
parents it seemed the center always took
the side of the parent who was going
with the transition
my concerns about this approach to
dissenting parents grew in 2019 she
writes when one of our doctors actually
testified in a custody hearing against a
father who opposed A Mother's wish to
start their 11 year old daughter on
puberty blockers
now there are so many more disturbing
details in this piece I'll post on
Instagram and on Twitter and on my
website I encourage all of you to read
this to really understand what is
happening inside these clinics
they're not putting our children first
they're endangering our children now in
response to these whistleblower claims
the Missouri AG today announced an
investigation into this so-called
Hospital
the angle hopes Justice is done for
these poor little kids
before more have their bodies and their
minds destroyed
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else